do you feel happy here of course I'm
happy
here aren't you someone's here when was
the last time we had a visitor fo is a
really interesting one because there's
so many different stories that are
happening at the same time there's the
story that we think that's happening and
then there's the story that's really
happening therein lies what's very
exciting from a directorial point of
view at the core of it is a marriage in
crisis but you've got this element that
we are always as an audience slightly
behind the characters I need to have an
intimate understanding of your
marriage the good and the bad it's
between you and me what myself and G
were interested in is this story for all
of its kind of moving part as Junior and
hen's relationship grows and she begins
to feel secure you then have another
twist in the tail that destroys all of
that I think they were kind of the
architectural elements of the writing
and the excitement of what we had ahead
of us there's all these wonderful
metaphors in the story how the decaying
marriage reflects the decaying planet
and these really philosophical questions
sit in the fabric of the storytelling
GTH is very curious in the best way and
I think that's exactly who you need to
be telling this
story just concentrating on these three
performances was exciting because GTH
has such a connection to the characters
and the stories that he's telling I was
very drawn to how he shows families and
relationships and love between cop
it's a feeling and when you have it it
is
exhilarating Patrice and GTH really
explored what a realistic future would
look like there's old and there's new
this film represents a fifth generation
Farmhouse but then it has the big
chicken factories and it has the drones
and it shows bits of what the future
will look
like it needed to be relatable we had to
really think around how we designed the
sets um how much te technology we saw
G's idea to make the audience believe in
the incredible aspect of the story you
need to ground everything in a reality
and not try to overdesign it you really
have to feel the ghost room you almost
have to feel that the house has been
lived in over time the house stays
anchored in a certain past and only the
futuristic elements come from teris who
brings changes to their lives they going
to the installation I don't know listen
to me I don't like how to show up here I
think Mattias was so wonderful at
working with G and finding the camera in
the room and finding who to follow so
that we could really explore the
characters to make sure that we're
getting both of their Journeys G is
extremely precise about what he wants in
terms of composition lens size camera
movement even light he knows what the
film needs and that kind of feeling
within the house very much has his
directorial style all over it what if we
decide
let's decide together
[Music]
okay